-Math.
DAVE BROWN: Maths-type stuff.
-Do the math for me.
-This is the story of maths.
VI HART: Say you're me
in your math class.
-Science without maths.
DR. LYNNE MURPHY: Emotions
run high how about
maths versus math.
If you're an American living in
Britain, you will have been
corrected a lot and told things
like, what's wrong with
you Americans?
Don't you realize that there's
an S on the end of
mathematics, so you need an
S on the end of math.
BRADY HARAN: You are an American
living in Britain.
DR. LYNNE MURPHY: I am an
American living in Britain.
BRADY HARAN: Tell me about how
much problem this causes you.
DR. LYNNE MURPHY: Well, I mean,
it's enough that I now
say maths, because I don't
want to have an argument.
Well, it's only in the 19th
century that people started
abbreviating mathematics.
And at that point, the
first known use of
math is from 1847.
That's what the "Oxford English
Dictionary" has recorded.
There, you know, people are
using it with a full stop-- or
a period, as we Americans say.
And there's not a lot of
evidence there that people
were actually saying it.
It looks like it started out as
an abbreviation in writing
and not an abbreviation
in speech.
So that starts around 1847.
It's not until 1911 that we
see maths with an S. And
again, it looks like
people weren't
probably saying it then.
They were probably just writing
it in course catalogs
and things like.
English people will say to me,
there's an S on the end of
mathematics, so you
need to put the S
on the end of maths--
which I counter, but we don't
put the last letter from other
abbreviations onto the end
of those abbreviations.
So when you say fax instead of
facsimile, you don't say
facsie, just because there's
an E on the end of fax.
So that argument that you should
put the last letter
onto an abbreviation, I don't
quite understand.
Except that a lot of people say
this because they believe
that mathematics is plural.
And so you have to use the
S to mark the plural in
mathematics on maths.
The problem with that is that
mathematics isn't plural.
You don't say there are
two mathematics that I
need to look at.
And when you make maths or
mathematics agree with a verb,
you make it agree with
a singular verb,
not a plural one.
So you don't say mathematics
are interesting.
You say maths is interesting.
So there's plenty of linguistic
evidence that
that's a singular.
But people see the S and think,
if there's an S on the
end of a noun, it
must be plural.
BRADY HARAN: Does that mean
Americans have this deeper
understanding of what
constitutes plural?
DR. LYNNE MURPHY: No,
I don't think so.
I think it's that-- and I don't
think, necessarily, that
British people put the S on the
end because they did think
it was plural.
It was the habit that was got
into, probably because it was
first a written form.
And in written forms, you might
abbreviate things all
sorts of ways.
But once they saw the S, they
interpreted it as plural.
So this is what we call
a folk etymology.
You see something with a form
that looks familiar, and you
assume it has that form
for a reason.
And so people are always looking
for reasons why their
form of the languages is more
logical than the other.
And the problem is that language
on the vocabulary
level doesn't follow logic.
Vocabulary is just,
anything goes.
BRADY HARAN: Which is ironic
when you're discussing
mathematics, which is
so the opposite.
DR. LYNNE MURPHY: [LAUGHTER]
Yeah, absolutely.
One cat is fluffy.
Two cats are fluffy.
So in English, we mark the
number in a sentence in
various places.
We can do it with a numeral.
We can do it with
a plural suffix.
And we do it on the verb.
So math is fun.
The question comes, when you've
got that S there, what
are you going to put here?
Is this S telling you that
it's plural or not?
And the fact of the matter is,
people say maths is fun.
They don't say maths are fun.
In linguistics, when things are
wrong, we put a star in
front of them, an asterisk,
to signal that.
So that's kind of--
BRADY HARAN: That's
the smoking gun.
DR. LYNNE MURPHY: That's
You don't have one mathematic,
two mathematics.
BRADY HARAN: I now believe
you that it's not plural.
Why do we have an S on the
end of mathematics?
DR. LYNNE MURPHY: OK.
Well, it's a long story,
starting in Greek--
which doesn't have an S on the
end of mathematics, but it did
have an A, which was the
plural ending there.
BRADY HARAN: So that
was mathematika.
DR. LYNNE MURPHY: Mathematika.
So that A there was taking an
adjective for mathematic and
making it into a noun.
So the way to make an adjective
into a noun in Greek
was to add this A, which
was a plural marker.
So what it meant was all
the mathy stuff, right?
So all the mathematical stuff.
And so you get that in physics,
you get that in
linguistics, you get that
in all of these sort of
Greek-rooted studies
of meanings.
BRADY HARAN: What, the A
became an S, did it?
DR. LYNNE MURPHY: So the A
became an S in English because
the people who were taking these
words from Greek knew
enough Greek to know that
was the plural.
Brought the plural
into English.
But then it evolved away from
the plural very quickly in
English, because we weren't
treating it as meaning all the
things to do with X. We were
treating it as meaning, the
study of X, which is a more
singular meaning.
Well, the thing about language
is people get very
nationalistic about
these things.
Your language is a huge
part of your identity.
If somebody else says something
a different way, you
want to believe that the way
you say it is right.
I've been confronted about
people who are angry when
people say, "you do the math"
instead of "you do the maths,"
as an expression.
And I think that's kind of rich,
because I believe the
original was American, and it
was originally "you do the
math."
But yeah, I'm not sure
why this one
exercises people so much.
Maybe because it is more of a
scientific group who's worried
about it, or because you think
that since mathematics is
precise, the word for it
should be standardized.
I'm not sure.
Aluminium versus aluminum is
the other one that really,
really gets people.
So that sort of goes along with
that hypothesis that it's
the scientific ones that
really rankle.
-I don't know about Americans in
general, but I can say that
for me, when I moved to London,
I was really thrown by
the double numbers thing
for quite a while.